[Musique]
un chant traditionnel pour un moment
significatif j'annonce que le Canada va
investir jusqu'à 800 millions de dollars
dans 4 grands projets de conservation
dirigé par les peuples autochtones d'un
bout à l'autre du pays qui représente un
total de près de 1 million de kilomètres
carrés des projets de conservation
pilotés par des peuples autochtones
réclamés depuis longtemps une étape
importante vers la réconciliation
pour que les peuples autochtones du
Canada puissent réaliser leur vision de
la conservation et de la protection de
la biodiversité lance ce chef autochtone
une annonce qui arriva point en ce
premier jour de la COP15 un message
envoyé au négociateur alors qu'un des
objectifs phares de cette rencontre est
de s'entendre pour protéger 30% des
terres et des mères d'ici 2030 et
d'inclure les peuples autochtones dans
le processus
nous allons continuer de faire le
travail de façon à agressif parce que on
se doit de protéger nos territoires pour
les futurs générations futures et on se
doit de démontrer aussi l'exemple aux
autres pays du monde
une annonce qui fait écho ici au message
lancé par des autochtones de partout sur
la planète
Barbuda il voit dans ses collaborations
la clé de la préservation de la planète
my merci
pour faire place à ses projets
collaboratifs de conservation il faudra
freiner les aires de industrielles et
celles des banques est-ce que nous
demandons à deux montrer toutes les
institutions financières c'est de
présenter des plans des plans qui
puissent être vérifiés pour une
transition accélérée vers les énergies
renouvelables un message entre autres
dirigé aux grandes banques du Canada qui
ont augmenté leurs investissements dans
l'industrie des énergies fossiles en
2021 et la borne du Canada elle aurait
même doublé son aide à l'industrie ici
Elisa serres Radio-Canada Montréal